[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
happy
happy friday
my voice
oh boy my voice
hear it can you hear my voice maybe
we'll just have to i'll do my best alex
jones all day i'll do my best alex jones
all day long i'll just i'll continue to
do alex jones my voice is uh is still
struggling
i apologize for the voice
we are live and we are here
so we'll make the best of it we'll
exercise the vocal cords we'll get it
going i'll do my best alex jones all day
that's right debbie says your voice
my voice
oh
happy friday
everyone says good morning to the
[ __ ] fan good morning good morning
good morning
uh mj is feeling pity on me
that i have to do alex jones is that is
that what it is do i need
you you pity me because i have to do the
alex jones voice
as i exercise my vocal chords more you
see see if i do my normal voice i'm
almost there i'm almost there almost
there we'll get through this i promise
we're going to do the shitless roundup
we're going to do the [ __ ] list roundup
today we're also gonna do bonehead of
the week
i thought i had my voice back
uh earlier i was exercising it
and i i clearly don't have it back yet
but we do have a lot of things to get to
today
um we have
we have roger stone tapes and a few
other things to get to
so
let's get to it
let's just go let's just go straight to
the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
so
the [ __ ] list
yeah we're back we're back we're back
see that i'm getting better at it i'm
getting better at the voice i'm getting
better knowing where my octaves are so
just hang with us and all you people out
there
on the audio version you're just gonna
have to put up with my voice either that
or not download this episode i don't
know what to tell you
hang with me
watch we'll watch a lot of video today
so let's go to the timeline
let's see
um
if i can get this zoom to work there we
go you guys seen last night um we did
the interview yesterday of the the
gibson go
data leak
and uh
midas touch had us on the show the clip
on the show last night
here's what they said right right right
here's what they said on the show let's
play that
we don't have phone numbers right right
right so like it's like if anything goes
awry and they need to respond
there's a person that might have the
email but there might be these tentacles
of donations that are tied back to that
and they're trying to
maybe they're trying to hide by
different zip codes and different names
of who actually has that email right you
look at this one there's three from the
united states there's one from canada
right i actually went out and found the
email address and i did find the email
address it's in japan
so there you have uh tony michaels and
gabe sanchez both just such incredible
hosts of the show we're gonna have a big
announcement with the tony michaels
podcast coming up early next week some
of you may have even heard me hint at it
if you listen to this show earlier today
but i'm thinking maybe just maybe we
bring tony's show under the midas
umbrella and so i just i'm loving what
they're doing there but if you want to
hear more about the trucker convoy and
its financing and why the financing is
so shady and why it should be looked
into listen to this episode of the tony
michaels podcast wherever you find
podcasts
great great great
we really appreciate
uh midas touch
partnering with us
pathetic absolutely pathetic maybe i'll
just talk softer and i'll talk way way
into the microphone you guys won't see
me much but i'll just talk a lot softer
i have my gain all the way down because
normally i'm really loud i'm normally
really really loud so i gotta turn the
gain all the way down on the microphone
but today i'm just gonna have to talk
straight into the microphone really
lightly and keep my octave at the same
level
i don't know i don't know you guys gonna
bear with me through this maybe maybe
not
so thanks
thanks uh minus touch for
um showing our clip last night on your
podcast and uh you guys should really go
check out that interview
it is two hours long
two hours long excuse me
but uh
so subscribe to the youtube channel
we're like one
one
um
subscriber away from a thousand right
now which is kind of crazy i didn't
think we would uh get to a thousand this
quickly but we have there's my voice you
hear it you hear it there it is there it
is see it now i found it i found it if i
could just keep it right here for like
two hours
and i'll just talk lightly in the
microphone i'll have to hide behind the
microphone so i can talk directly into
it
but i think i found my voice now i think
there it is
okay all right
one subscriber more so give a thumbs up
uh
also subscribe to the youtube channel
so that way we can
do some super chats and some things um
the kev independent here
gives the russian losses as of march 4th
as of today
the
approximate troops
that are russian losses is almost 9 200
which is crazy um 252 tanks 37
helicopters
um i actually posted a video on the on
my instagram
of a uh of a
a plane being shot down which is kind of
cool
which is kind of cool
so
um
breaking roger stone linked to joel
greenberg matt gatt's friend who pled
guilty to sex trafficking and corruption
charges
a photo from washington post story show
stonestone's phone
this implicates greenberg in january 6.
the gates
case
is perhaps far bigger than imagined um
you can see the uh
the pictures of roger stone's phone here
and it looks like
um maybe he's been mowing something no i
don't know it has joel greenberg's uh
text message here um
obviously joe greenberg has something to
do with january 6. the reason why the
reason why joe greenberg has something
to do with january 6
is because he was seeking a pardon so
why wouldn't he go in support of donald
trump remaining to be dictator of the
united states why wouldn't he do that of
course he would and why wouldn't roger
stone have him there roger stone
apparently got paid a hundred thousand
dollars
by john greenberg that's the story
so that he could pimp a pardon
to trump
good stuff um
sensitive i was looking for this video
this morning
about
uh about
trump trucks
you guys seen this um this uh
truck rally thing
and they don't have semi trucks they're
like trump trucks you know these big
jacked up trucks you know these little
these little dick makeup vehicles
and i remembered i did a little ditty
um
i don't remember what episode it was but
i did it on the podcast about trump
trucks
and with trump flags and how they're
heavily regulated
so
i um i was looking for that video this
morning and if you notice here it says
we put
twitter
we put a warning on this tweet
it might have sensitive content
i can appeal the warning but i don't
give a [ __ ] they can label me all they
want but it says have you seen these
stupid [ __ ] trucks with the trump
flags heavily regulated no [ __ ]
that's what it says so i'm guessing it's
the video it's the video that they want
to regulate or that they want to censor
i don't know um
here's the here's the the actual video
or the uh
the tweet that i did this morning and
then here's the video you guys tell me
since my voice isn't working
maybe i'll just play this and this will
be my voice let's do that
stupid trucks with all the truck flags
on the back of them
every single one of those trucks
has walked on down to the tyrannical
government's office to license those
[ __ ]
they license them and i guarantee you
almost every single one of them has a
goddamn mortgage against it at a bank so
the end so the bank requires them to
have an insurance policy so then they
gotta they go to the fdic bank which is
insured by the federal government that
tyrannical government that you talk
about then they run on down to the
interns office to buy a policy that's
regulated by the tyrannical government
and they sign up for an insurance policy
for their [ __ ] little dick truck
because they got a dick complex
not only do they got a dick complex with
their big tires and their jacked up
truck they got to have a 40-foot flag on
it that says trunk 20 20.
and their confederate flag because you
know america
every single one of those that you see
every [ __ ] one of them
heavily heavily regulated heavily
licensed and heavily insured
but the guns inside the truck
the guns inside the truck maybe not so
[ __ ] much
so that was the dismount there
um with the guns
the point that i was trying to make
is the uh the trucks are regulated but
the guns inside the truck are not
regulated that was the uh
the point that i was trying to make
so there you have a a rant with my
normal voice
so i don't know you guys tell me did is
that is that too sensitive is that too
sensitive for um
i don't know
and see it even tells me the tweet is
unavailable here
because it's too sensitive
see that see how it's got the tweet is
unavailable
look at that
now weird
i didn't know that i was looking for
this video
but
they apparently have labeled it
sensative
uh mayo says i can't wait for roger
stone to rot away in prison
yeah i think a lot of people are
ready for that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] to
run away in prison
um we're probably gonna get more word
and more word on that
oh speaking speaking of rotting in
prison
uh you know that john eastman is and
trump are losing their court battles
they are jesus they are losing their
core battles
for
a
attorney-client privilege
um i did this video
it was last year right before january 6.
this is before january 6 this is when
they had the plan for vice president
mike pence to overturn our election our
free and fair election
do i sound like alex jones today i feel
like i sound like alex jones i feel like
i sound like alex jones call off ken
says call it off
your voice is way too bad
i'm not i don't quit never never will i
quit ever ever ever
let's play this clip
give you a little [ __ ] dose of
reality here if the vice president
really did have the power to pick who
the president was why in the [ __ ]
hell would joe biden pick donald trump
in 2017 you dumb [ __ ] this
deluded little [ __ ] loophole exists
us radical socialist commies would have
took power and took over the country you
dumb [ __ ] idiot [ __ ] up a better
[ __ ] plan would you please [ __ ] them
give you a little [ __ ] dose of
reaction so
that that is
last year before january 6
when i did that video
uh when they had the plan for mike pence
to overturn the government
we all knew that's what the plan was
they were saying it out loud
they were saying it out loud
uh debbie says
uh i sound like alex jones use the
helium app i don't have an app
i don't have an app
mj says [ __ ] it you got this you recover
over the weekend if you reset rest it oh
yeah
absolutely
absolutely we're going to make it
through i don't
we're not gonna quit we're not gonna
quit it's too important to quit
way too important okay
uh let's see
this is a uh
i said how about you take your little
book and shove it up your ass bill barr
it's an interview that lester holt did
with bill barr
about how he quit
as attorney general of the united states
uh debbie says she still loves me i
think what you're saying is even though
i sound even though i sound like alex
jones today
that makes it worse when i do that
sorry
okay
let's move forward let's move forward in
this tragedy of my voice
ken says [ __ ] him yeah [ __ ] him i'll
just i'll just do the i'll just keep
going here
and we'll keep keep it going you just
have to skip this episode if you don't
want to listen to it on the audio
version but we are doing bone end of the
week today we're doing bone end of the
we're
yep let's just play the clip and i told
him that all this stuff was
and uh about election fraud
and uh
you know it was wrong to be shoveling it
out the way his team was
and he started asking me about different
theories and i had the answers i was
able to tell him this is wrong because
of this you're trying to set him
straight yes and and and you know he
listened
he
he was obviously getting very angry
about this i said okay well look i
understand you're upset with me
and i'm perfectly happy to tender my
resignation and then
boom he slaps the desk he slapped the
desk and he said accepted
accept it
and then boom he slapped it again accept
it
go home don't go back to your office go
home
you're done
so there you have it
oh the great story that we knew
already from
bill barr about why he held this
information from the american people
[ __ ]
the jobs report is out today
i asked when the unemployment rate drops
to 3.8
is that a good thing uh is this probably
biden's fault
i think so thanks brandon i would have
done a uh
a headline video if it weren't for
my voice i just have to go really slow
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
um
jose
jose says 1k right here you're welcome
[ __ ] him thank you jose for a thousand
thank you for a thousand subscribers we
should celebrate
everyone celebrating the comments
apparently we've reached
a thousand subscribers here let's check
it out
we are
we're at a thousand two now keep going
don't stop keep keep getting subscribers
keep going uh mj says
hope gabe's voc vocals are
rested yeah maybe we'll just let gabe
run the uh bonehead of the week
and i'll just
nod
and go yep
yep
yep
okay duty to warn um
reports that moscow exchange is closed
for the fifth day in a row
can you believe that the fifth day
the whole week
the stock market in russia has been
closed
collapse
collapse
remember when the uh
cheeto dust mobster
grandpa poopy pants
donald trump said sanctions aren't gonna
work
remember sanctions aren't gonna work
well
it definitely crushed their economy and
it's crushing it more and more
well christina makes a good point
market can't crash if you don't open it
but if you don't know open it there's no
commerce
there's no commerce
so we're gonna keep going
keep pressing forward
there's
more um news out of
ukraine
uh this morning
um let me see if i can find i think i
posted it
um it looks really bad there here's a uh
here's a picture of kharkiv
um it's not good there and then um
let's give credit for that one that's
not mine so let's give credit there
uh let's see we got um
um
i thought i had another video that i
posted
of
the yeah here it is
luke uh
let's uh back this up so you guys can
see it
those of you what uh listening
um this is an aerial photo
of i believe it's uh kiev
i believe
uh so let's let's watch
[Music]
[Music]
mass devastation
um
really it seems like warm war crimes
have been committed
uh a lot of these buildings are
residential and apartment buildings
excuse me
um so that's not good we have
[ __ ] lindsey graham
is there brutus in russia
there is a more successful colonel
stoffenberg in the russian army our
military
the only way this ends is for somebody
in russia to take this guy out
he's talking about putin his [ __ ]
buddy putin you [ __ ] idiot you
[ __ ]
have been placating and propping up
putin's puppets and now you just want
him to be murdered by his own people now
you want a stoffenberg to get rid of
putin
to make it easy for you
to answer
for the [ __ ] that you've done and the
[ __ ] that you perpetuated here [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you you [ __ ]
you would be doing your country in the
world the great service i'm sure
i'm sure whoever would
take out vladimir putin would do a great
job and a great service to get rid of
all the compromise
that is on
the republican party including you lady
g you [ __ ]
uh let's see
do here's a statement
from zielinski to putin i'm gonna read
it to you and then i'll play it
uh good lord what do you want leave our
land if you want to leave now sit down
with me at the negotiating table
but not from 30 meters away
like with macron and sculpts
sit down with me and talk what are you
afraid of
we're no threat to anyone he's he's
[ __ ] calling putin a little [ __ ]
he's calling putin a little [ __ ]
listen to this
story
hey vladimir putin
this is what a leader looks like
this is what a leader looks like
standing up to putin looks like donald
trump you [ __ ] [ __ ]
salinsky ain't no [ __ ]
at all
no [ __ ]
doesn't wimp out doesn't [ __ ] run
[ __ ] no
stands tall with his people as a patriot
for for real values like democracy
not oh i can't get a hamburger
i can't do the whiny voice really but
i can't get it i can't i can't do that
octave
that octave isn't there yet
it'll come back to me probably tomorrow
or sunday that octave and i'll be able
to do that voice
later on in the week next week
but it really it really is does say
something
when the president of ukraine when his
people are being killed and shelled
by an aggressor
a war criminal that warcraft he says sit
down with me leave my land
sit down with me face to face belly to
belly [ __ ]
what are you afraid of
putin's afraid
that his people will know he's weak
although they already know that
uh occupied democrats reported yesterday
breaking ukrainian firefighters are
unable to reach
the largest nuclear power plant in
europe as it burns because russians
russian troops
are shooting at them
um as you know
uh
they're committed committing war crime
after war crime after war crime
um there was even reports that they're
trying to uh
take down tv towers take over tv
broadcasting to broadcast their
propaganda
uh it will continue
it will continue it won't stop
it won't stop
um
speaking of russians
have you guys seen the
gibson go interview yesterday here's the
clip
that midas touch played on their twitter
account
you guys if you subscribe to the youtube
channel
you can go watch the uh
the full episode
it's episode 88
um with high fidelity he's the co-host
of radicalized pod
radicalized truth survives podcast but
on twitter it's at radical icepod so go
follow their their page
but hi by here
he really laid it out in the interview
of what he thinks is happening
with the data from the ottawa truckers
convoy that [ __ ] front
you know the people who wish wish they
even had an ounce of the [ __ ] courage
and patriotism
that the ukrainians are showing right
now
let's listen i looked at email address
to zip code first name last name to
email address
email address to credit card type
this is what i found man over 2 000
email addresses appear twice what the
[ __ ]
204 appear three times
46
and you can see the numbers right right
right there is one email address that
appears 16 [ __ ] times now wait a
second wait a second that seems that
seems totally fine now wait a second now
wait no because because if i wanted to
if i wanted to donate 16 times i might
use my email address the same email
address each time and that is absolutely
fair and i understand that and that is
organic right i did look through some of
the duplicates and i found there were
some people like i was able to identify
people and i'll show you that later on
there were organic multiple donations
right that's right but what makes these
different well let me show you so what i
found here here was the first one i
looked at right and this was four
records so i have four donations i have
four different names
as you can see right there donation
first donation you're saying the first
and last name are completely different
on each one of these as well on each one
we have alyssa jordan
richard and jerry
right okay it sounds like all of them
sounds like a whole family of them yeah
yeah except all of them have the same
email address
with four different zip codes what the
[ __ ]
ford is this is this isn't like a house
you guys can't just share emails what
the [ __ ] going on right what the [ __ ]
well so here's my thought right
maybe these emails are emails that have
somebody that will answer any questions
to that email but they're using that to
launder the donations to that email does
that make sense like hey i've got this
one
email the email is the contact point in
other words yeah yeah we don't have
phone numbers right right right so like
it's like if anything goes awry and they
need to respond
there's a person that might have the
email but there might be these tentacles
of donations that are tied back to that
and they're trying to
maybe they're trying to hide by
different zip codes and different names
of who actually has that email right you
look at this one there's three from the
united states there's one from canada
right i actually went out and found the
email address and i did find the email
address it's in japan
it's in japan
now what a great episode you guys gotta
go watch that um carter says
tony sounds like lego batman maybe
that's what i should do
is do my batman voice
i was practicing
while i was on mute
maybe i could just do my batman voice it
sounds pretty good
oh [ __ ]
ah
you i looked at that yes you guys got me
all kinds of crazy today
okay
let's go to the uh tweety tweets and the
trinity trends here
um let's see
what do we have i actually didn't biden
boom
is trending
um i would say
that
this has to do with these
678 000 jobs
that were created in the month of
february
which
unemployment fell
to 3.8 percent
how do you like them apple jumpers
amy lynn says
[Laughter]
amy says u.s added 678 000 jobs
and on unemployment
fell to 3.8
in february how do you like that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
how do you like them apples bite and
boom thanks for your tweet amy thanks
for your tweet
thank you for your tweet
um christopher says biden boom getting
louder the u.s economy added 678 000
jobs in february exceeding economist
expectations
yes thank you keep pointing this out and
boom
democrats deliver
uh
someone was uh i
posted my tweet
over on instagram and uh
someone over on instagram said
well what about inflation
you know that [ __ ] well here's the
thing
here's the thing about
uh prices going up in inflation
the reason why we have inflation is
twofold we have corporate greed
and we also have a very hot economy
because consumer confidence is up
and the reason why we know that consumer
confidence is up
is because people are still spending
money
and
unemployment is dropping and jobs are
being created because there's demand
that's how we know that's why inflation
is up
the legitimate reason why inflation is
up
is because there's demand
and there wasn't as much of a supply
like we came out of the pandemic
and a shortage of production
and consuming
now there's demand for consuming
whether it be good services restaurants
bars groceries gasoline whatever
so you can't say economy bad because
price is high
that's really [ __ ] dumb
now you can say price is high that
affects americans
that affects their pocketbooks that
affects how much they can spend
you can say that
but that's when you have to have the
discussion of what is our if it's our
government's fault if it's biden's fault
or it's the democrats fault
why is it their fault
democrats are the only one that
delivered inflation protection through
the child tax credit
republicans voted no
for that inflation protection
democrats delivered that inflation
protection republicans and joe manchin
destroyed that inflation protection
because that inflation protection
extension
for the child tax credit
was in the big bird bill
the bill back better act
that republicans and joe
manchin wouldn't even debate
so
if you're if you're concerned out there
about the price of fuel and think that's
a sign of the economy
then you're not paying attention
you're not paying attention and it only
makes it obvious when you talk about the
price of gas at the pump
that you're a [ __ ] dumbass
and you don't understand what you're
talking about and that's fine
if you don't want to understand it
that's cool we're okay with that
dumb dumbs do dumb things
i been saying that dum-dums do dumb
things because they do dum-dums do dumb
things you don't know what you don't
know
right
you don't know what you don't know
and in this case a lot of americans
don't know that joe biden doesn't have a
gasoline price button on his desk
he doesn't have an inflation button
on his desk
he doesn't have an unemployment button
on his desk to think that joe biden is
the only one solely responsible
for gasoline prices then you have to
believe that joe biden is the only one
solely
responsible
for the for the unemployment rate which
he's not
joe biden is not solely responsible for
the unemployment rate
i mean he is the president while that
unemployment rate is what it is
he is instituting the policies and using
the power that he has
to possibly draw down the unemployment
rate to make the economy better for all
americans
but he doesn't get to choose what it is
dumb dumb
so dum-dums do dumb things they really
say dumb things too
which the main dumb thing that they say
is gas high
economy bad
no no
gas high for a lot of different reasons
economy good
economy good because it's heated now we
need to cut back on the corporate greed
and the gouging for sure i 100 agree
with that i think there's a lot of
companies and a lot of profiteers out
there taking advantage of the consumer
confidence
there is consumer confidence
that's why they're able to gouge you
if there was no demand
they couldn't gouge you does that make
sense
what are they going to gouge you if you
don't have demand like if they can't
even give away their service
they can't gouge you
that's how capitalism works dumb
[ __ ]
if what you're selling no one wants it
you can't raise the price
you have to drop the price that's how it
works
it it really is [ __ ]
irritating
that people who walk around talking
about freedomness freedom that i want my
freedom constitution this is not a
democracy this is a republic all this
nonsense i'm a conservative
what whatever i don't like big
government
free market get the [ __ ] out of here
you don't you're not even making [ __ ]
sense if you say
the reason why the economy is bad is
because gas prices are high you don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
you don't
you have no clue
you you haven't even got to the basics
of what our economy even is
because gas prices to some degree are
based on demand
now a lot of it has to do with opec
but they they
they create false demand
by starving the supply
right they intentionally do that so
there's that aspect
but you don't even need to talk about
that aspect to make someone understand
of what a [ __ ] of what the price is
and yes there's always demand for
essentials
basics
commodities
there's always that demand food
water
fuel
but there wasn't that demand there
wasn't the demand for fuel
now there is
so yeah gas is going to be high
but why is gas high not not
not gas high economy bad it's why is gas
high
that's the question it's not biden dumb
[ __ ] and really honestly if you think
gas is high because of biden you're not
paying attention gas would be much
higher if it wasn't for the actions of
our president
whether you [ __ ] like him or not
i really don't think that the
the idea to dip into the reserves is all
that great for us strategically
it's good for us economically but not
good for us strategically
i think to keep dipping into reserves
opec and other countries around the
world could take advantage of that
they could use that they know we're
gonna do it
they know biden's vulnerable in that
area to make sure
that he lets the people know the
dum-dums know that he's trying to keep
gas prices low as best he can with what
power he has
that [ __ ] reserve is a strategic
reserve and yes we have a strategic
problem right now
but we don't know
what the
if that's going to be permanent or
temporary
so what i'm saying is i don't know that
it's the best thing for us long term to
keep dipping into our reserve
because we keep having problems that are
outside our control
we can't we can't control
that we have to shut off russia
at this point we can't control that yet
it's just something that we can't do
and a lot of it has to do with nuclear
weapons
and rather vladimir putin would use them
now i don't think i don't think he's
gonna launch nukes at us
but we don't want him to launch nukes at
anybody
there's humanity at play here
so yeah we have to cut off russia and
the rest of the world has to cut off
russia and putin mainly
and punish
punish putin's russia
that's what we have to do
but that doesn't mean that doesn't mean
that it's a long-term thing it could be
i don't know
but the gasoline prices
don't mean economy bad
actually
wind all the way back i'm old enough to
remember
in 2008 you guys remember this
there was this thing that happened in
2008 i don't know if you remember or not
maybe you do maybe it was insignificant
to your life
and your personal economy but there was
a huge crash
huge
we called it the great recession here
but it was all around the world in 2008
now because of that
gasoline went to an all-time low
gasoline are you hearing me out there
you [ __ ]
trump humping idiots
under barack obama
after he took his office
gasoline went to an all-time low
it wasn't because barack obama's some
kind of [ __ ]
super genius with gas prices
that's not what it was
it was because
the market fell there was no demand
everything dropped out of the market
that's why you [ __ ] idiot
so for you to say gas price is high
economy bad
you're not you you're you're not
remembering anything about not only how
the economy works
but
how it's affected you in the past
you really are a [ __ ] idiot the other
thing too if you're bitching that your
[ __ ] big ass trump pickup truck
takes 500 to fill up
well consider going and getting a prius
you dumb [ __ ]
or go go to your [ __ ] your little
[ __ ] boy
elon musk and get an electric car
wait that your gas bill will be way
cheaper
way cheaper
if you go get you a tesla and then
frankly you won't even have a gasoline
bill really
i mean you'll have an electric bill
these people really
they really are [ __ ] stupid
i'm glad you guys remember christina
said she lost her house during a
foreclosure
a lot of americans did christina
a lot of them did
and we should remember that we should
remember that time
yes we to to know that how our economy
is now we have to remember the way it
was of course
and first christina that's not an easy
thing to remember
and for a lot of americans it's not an
easy thing to remember
but you have to know what it was to know
what it is now
that's all i'm saying
all right let's let's move on past the
biting boom moscow mitch is trending
uh let's see
um
brooklyn dad defiance says anyone else
wondering how much money moscow mitch
and lindsey graham are losing with
russian sanctions
that's a decent question
i i always wondered
what our little oligarch wannabe family
here in this country the trumps how much
money they're losing
um so moscow mitch is trending
we're gonna do uh
the uh bone end of the week here in just
a little bit
um gabe's gonna join us hopefully he'll
do most the talking
uh nato rejects ukraine's demand for a
no-fly zone
um
one of the reasons why this no-fly zone
is um
is kind of taking place is
um we don't want uh
uh ramen here's
wanting me to check
uh it looks like
um
robin
this has to do with moscow mitch i think
that's
yeah okay hang on a second let me uh
let me pull this up here
you guys know if you dm me
so before we move on stephanie rule says
a leg deripaska daraposka's aluminum
project in kentucky
she responded to robin here
robin wrote well this is interesting i
wonder if there's any connection to
russian owners of aluminum factory the
former guy lifted sanctions
barack obama had in place if you guys
remember the sanctions that barack obama
put on russians
the factory ran out of funds after
leader mcconnell won his election
um here is uh stephanie
the reply why on earth is the state of
kentucky's retirement fund so heavily
invested in a russian bank hmm
seems kind of interesting
seems kind of interesting
i wonder that must be the uh the reason
why moscow mitch
is uh trending is that the reason why
robin thank you for the tweet
i honestly have been trying to exercise
my voice this morning so i wasn't uh
paying too much attention uh of the
trends uh the trends are new to me this
morning believe it or not
so
i thank you robin i thank you for giving
me that day
um
let's go back to the uh
oh should i give i should have gave
stephanie the
oh man
i feel horrible now i should have gave
stephanie
credit
we gotta give stephanie credit
give stephanie credit here
we'll give her credit on this one we'll
retweet it thank you stephanie
and i i used to watch stephanie when i
had cable i don't have cable anymore so
i don't get to watch stephanie stephanie
you can come on the show if you'd like
you're always welcome
always welcome
um
like i said i don't i don't really know
boston marathon supreme court
reinstating decisions for convicted
boston marathon bomber
um so it looks like
um the boston marathon bomber will be um
his death sentence is
reinstituted
uh megan mccain is trending
maybe
scary larry says megan mccain does not
want kamala harris
sent to
um
butcher rest or warsaw because she
doesn't think kamala harris is a serious
person and you post this picture of her
hot toddy lisa says i should have a hot
toddy
is it then because of my voice yeah
maybe i'll have one later maybe i'll
take a [ __ ] nap
a couple of them
and just take a nap
although
sleeping doesn't help the voice because
you know it they like stu it's you know
it's all stove up
yesterday i had problems with the voice
today it's worse
but yesterday i didn't have to talk a
lot we played the interview so
it worked today not so much
let's see
i know i don't want to talk about megan
mccain
don't make me talk about megan mccain
for [ __ ] sake
roger stone let's go to this roger stone
tapes
a new documentary footage shows roger
stone behind the scenes to overturn the
2020 election
and secure
preemptive pardons for himself
republicans in congress and pro-trump
movement after jan jan 6 rally
is this like a documentary that someone
was he was having them follow him around
he's like yeah come document my crimes
that's cool
yes that'll be awesome that'll make for
a great reality show
make for a great reality show
if you come follow me around and
document all the crimes especially the
crimes that i do with the president
united states
and members of congress that'll be
really cool can you imagine how many
people would watch that like maybe even
a jury
that wouldn't that be awesome
[ __ ] idiot
tristan says roger stone spent much of
january
fifth and six side by side with a man
who just pled guilty to seditious
conspiracy
for what he did
on january 5th and 6th
yeah so they're talking about the oath
keeper
um
that pled guilty to seditious conspiracy
we've had dakota adams and tasha adams
on the show here
tasha came on once gave an extended
interview about the founder of the tr
the treasonous um oath keepers
stewart rhodes
who is also charged with seditious
conspiracy
in the same conspiracy where the other
oath keeper has pled guilty joshua james
is his name
and the thing the thing that i think is
um
very telling here
is that when you have a conspiracy like
this
the whole purpose of the conspiracy is
to tie everyone in
so that way they turn on each other
so that they do not have to go to trial
the prosecutors that is they do not want
to go to trial on a conspiracy case they
don't
let's see here
kyle
says footage and detail in the story are
remarkable but maybe the most important
thing
a reminder that oath keeper joshua james
who just pled guilty said to seditious
conspiracy was that stone sign and a
critical moment
um so kyle here also reporting about the
the significance of having uh joshua
james as oath keeper apparently the
bodyguard
of roger stone um at the january 5th and
january 6th events
um also what is important about joshua
um
james or jones i think it's james sorry
joshua james is that he was in direct
contact
with stuart rhodes and he was following
orders of student stuart rhodes i
believe that's super important
because
who who was giving stuart rhodes orders
we've talked about that before here with
dakota adams his estranged son
and um i'm actually i think we're gonna
talk to dakota uh over the weekend and
then probably
get his take
uh on josh james joshua james um
pleading guilty to this seditious
conspiracy
and the the person that was at roger
stone's side on january 6 and january uh
fifth
and get uh um
dakota's take but more than that
get why stuart why you would report to
stuart also
um it seems that there's evidence
that stuart rhodes wanted them in
disguise
so and why that's significant why stuart
rhodes would want them to be in disguise
and why significant that they were or
weren't or wanted to be in disguise
why did stuart want that who was giving
joshua james orders
and who was giving stuart rhodes orders
like all that makes that all that's part
of the conspiracy here of january 5th
and january 6
of what happened
of what they wanted because they had the
qrf
the weapons stored and stashed across
the potomac
ready
to make sure that if at that if trump
the cheeto dust mobster
gave the order to take over the
situation at the capitol
in case there was violence
that they were ready
they were at the ready
well
one of the oath keepers who's tied up in
this index seditious conspiracy to
overthrow our government
and our free and fair election
who was in contact with the person who
had the go order on that qrf
was protecting roger stone
who we know
is in contact with the president of the
united states
and members of congress
not just about january 6 but also about
pardons
so why in the world why in the world
would joshua james be guarding
roger stone
and why in the world would roger stone
decide to not have
the proud boys which was the original
plan
to protect him and went with the oath
keepers why
why who gave that order
who who made the decision
that the proud boys wouldn't protect
roger stone anymore that it would be the
oath keepers
hmm
kind of funny we're going to ask dakota
that this weekend
so hopefully
he can give us some insight
into some of that
i think that's going to be important
important
let's see here
um so uh rogers don't rand oh rand paul
rand paul is trending because kentucky's
under investigation or under the
microscope i should say
maybe they'll be under investigation
with an aluminum plant in kentucky
maybe their senators should know about
this
lindsey graham is still trending of
course
because
lindsey graham is a piece of [ __ ]
he wants someone to murder vladimir
putin killing all the secrets
killing all the secrets that vladimir
putin has on on lindsey graham and his
friends
uh bill barr
is uh holding stories to write a book
he gave an interview with lester holt we
watched part of that earlier
um christopher says i don't want to hear
[ __ ] from beer bill barr unless it's
under oath at trump's trial
a hondo
percento uh chris thank you
um what's what's uh
representative ted lu say
bill barr refused to testify at
impeachment trial you guys remember this
he refused to testify
during the impeachment of donald trump
after the cheeto dust kangaroo coup
attempt
uh teluses and the former president so
that he could later write a book and
profit from it he should be ashamed for
withholding information in order to make
money off a tragedy
second impeachment because of former
potus
was so bad
it's true
it's [ __ ] gross
same way with maggie haberman
maggie if you can hear me you're welcome
on the show
i will challenge the [ __ ] out of you
why did you withhold information from
the american people
information that they should have known
about how the administration and donald
trump himself was destroying top secret
documents
you [ __ ]
you held it hoping
hoping that he wouldn't be president
that way you could profit off of it what
happened
maggie and bill barr what happened if he
was successful and he became the
dictator
and he seen you as dissidents because
you knew information that would damage
him
huh
then what
then what
let's see what else do we have here on
billboard as [ __ ]
billbar you [ __ ] stick that book
straight up your ass that's what i say
take take the book
all the copies every last copy of it
and that really mainly the hard copies
you know paperback you know we can roll
those up
but the hard copies definitely every
single copy
should be shoved up his fat ass
all right let's go back to the trinity
trends and the tweety tweets here i
don't wanna i don't wanna talk about my
voice is strained enough today i really
don't wanna talk about megan mccain
i really don't
mayor adams is trending rand paul is
trending again
um
we're waiting on gabe to do the uh
bonehead of the week here
uh let's see oh it looks like we're
getting closer
looks like we're getting closer he is
sending things here so that's a good
sign
that's a good sign
um that we're getting closer here you
guys did you guys check out the bone end
of the week the um
the actual uh
the poll
of course we know why these people are
the bone end of the week right we know
why
let's go let's go take a look at that
while we're waiting on gay beer we'll go
take a look at
the bonehead of the week poll
did you guys know we have a podcast page
you should go follow it on twitter it's
at tony michael's pod
we just got over a thousand on it today
too so that's kind of cool we got over a
thousand on uh youtube over a thousand
on the podcast page so spread that
around help us get some more subscribers
some more followers
yeah christina and bobo the clown she
won and you're giving away all the
secrets here
um she did she won she won let's see if
we can find the poll
we post there it is
there it is here we go who's the bone
end of the week
contestants governor kim reynolds lauren
bobert marjorie taylor green
here's the poll
turned out turned out you know just the
way i thought it would
i i figured that how this is how this
would go
so
i figured that's how it would go
i figured that much
um
speaking of
boneheads
let's go back to the trendy trends
let's see if we can uh
find another there's all kinds of
boneheads trending
of course mega mccain bonehead roger
stone bonehead the boston marathon
bonered a super [ __ ] bonehead
[Music]
russian bank it's trending that must be
the uh
must be the
the problem that they're having in
kentucky
let's see minus touch just posted
something who is responsible for
investing 13 million of state of
kentucky's teachers retirement fund into
a russian bank
that is now virtually insolvent hmm i
wonder who that is this is a massive
scandal that must be investigated
immediately
i don't know
i think i think
any of these russian oligarchs any of
this russian money
all of it should be investigated full
stop
top to bottom
inside out up and down so russian bank
is trending
gabe's having some technical
difficulties
got a type amount of message
you got a little
chat thread in the background it's a
secret chat you guys don't get to see it
you guys don't get to see you don't see
what i'm typing in
see see the voice works for that like
when i'm doing the evil voice
it works for that
let's see we're trying to get bonehead
of the week going here he's having a few
technical difficulties that's how this
stuff happens sometimes but we'll get
through it you know we'll get through it
so what do you guys think you think the
russian bank thing i think it's going to
be a pretty big deal
uh any russian bank russian oligarch
stuff at this point is really going to
make a big splash
in the universe
that we live in and i bet
i would almost bet that we uncover a lot
of stuff
from 2016.
what do you think i think we uncover a
lot of [ __ ] from 2016.
a lot of [ __ ]
i bet we do
uh that we didn't know before
would be my guess
i think so
um
let's see if there's any more
there's stephanie's
um
let's see here
uh might as also post update
the kentucky djs retirement system now
says they sold their stake
in 2022.
it remains baffling that kentucky would
invest in such a heavily invested
russian bank
it does not make a lot of sense
it does not make a lot of sense
uh let's see what else do we have here
travis says there's a
there is a post circulating that's
claiming that kentucky teacher's
retirement was the second largest
shareholder in russian bank
the investment dropped 95 both claims
are completely false do not spread them
okay well
we'll spread your message too
see this is how information is supposed
to work
right
it doesn't mean just because something's
wrong or false doesn't mean people
shouldn't say it
right it doesn't mean that people
shouldn't say it it just means that the
information should be
known as false is false information
we see that in effect when we have
president biden calling out putin for
his false flags he was trying to
perpetuate false information about
russia i mean excuse me about ukraine
and they were calling it out they were
saying the false information out loud so
there is validity in doing that
um i think we we have gabe joining us
gabe how are you hey what's up how are
you finally got your stuff yeah it's
getting a little better i'm exercising
it okay do i sound people thought i
sound like lego batman you
[Applause]
do i should i i thought i sounded like
alex jo alex jones this is my house
you're a bit on the alex jones side i
would say so it's like it's like lego
batman and alex jones combined
can you share your screen
and uh
and maybe talk about some stuff for just
a few minutes
i've had to drink a lot of water yeah
this morning yeah yeah i gotta
give me
one go ahead and go ahead and take see
if and and see if you can take over the
shitless round up here just
a few minutes
i'm uh i'm drowning over here in water
oh yeah
all right all right all right uh so that
means i gotta go onto twitter now yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah sure
crazy yeah you're gonna actually have to
take controls here all right let me go
to a break and then when we come back
yeah let's do that i mean
do you want to keep talking about
shitless stuff yeah go ahead go ahead go
ahead and find go through the trends
yeah find the trend that you want to
talk about you know how to sure this
works yeah yeah yeah we were just
talking about the russian bank thing and
um
uh travis was posting that um there was
uh false information being spread and i
was just saying that sometimes with
false information you have to spread it
to say that it's false right right hey
here's this piece of information and
it's fake yeah so there's you know
there's a balance there's a balance to
spreading
misinformation but saying it's
misinformation it's misinformation yeah
is it easier to talk like that it is it
is much easier to talk like this
and it sounds it sounds really bad it
sounds really like this is
this is uh this maybe you know you you
know what i guess that's timely because
batman just came out the new one the
matt reeves just came out just came out
maybe what i should do
is from now on come on as batman yeah
you should you should be like you should
be well you know batman stands for
justice and all but you could be like
the pro-democracy batman
you know
that's just like that that's the only
thing you fight is illegal justices
i don't fight crime we fight anti we
fight fascism
do you have do you have your your screen
going yet are you are you about to i
know you're going to commercial sorry
okay here let me get my screen share
your screen i'm going to go to
commercial when we come back it'll be
gabe that is helping you through the
[ __ ] list roundup wow let's let's go to
commercial all right we'll be right back
after this
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
drupists mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your drew today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
hey everyone what's going on it's gabe
tony is mia
drowning in water so uh he asked me to
do him a solid and take over
uh let's uh let's go through the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends as he
normally says
um all right so you know i was busy
working so i wasn't unable to follow
along so i'm gonna be going through
what's what people say in the chat as
well as when tony gets back if you give
me a thumbs up thumbs down on what you
guys actually covered
uh
all right so uh let's see uh tony did
you guys cover the roger stone stuff
the roger stone stuff yeah yeah you can
just give me a thumbs up thumbs down so
if you don't want to talk oh no i'm good
i'm good okay all right
no i think what i should do is get a
batman a batman mask that way
i can play the
should you should batman
uh you should get a a little filter on
right if you would have told me i would
have overnighted you a batman mask for
my house oh you have a batman of course
of course you do of course if you want
you could also do a darth vader one i've
got that you know okay well you know or
if you would rather i just put the mask
on move my mouth you talk and i navigate
or you navigate the screen we can do
that as well all right so what are you
what are you looking what are you
looking in here you guys notice gabe
does the dark mode on his computer yeah
i said the white i have
it's the you know it's uh the [ __ ] list
after hours oh okay yeah yeah four hours
version well it's also it's also you
know the the the dark screen also takes
up less energy on the computer so i'm
just trying to be efficient with my
battery you know treat that puppy nice
yeah well i think everyone i i think
everyone knew why the hell i had to had
to uh take a quick break there right you
had to go it's okay
i've drank like
six gallons of water this morning to try
to get my voice back
of ice water and i've had like 12
coffees because what i was trying to do
is hot cold hot cold i didn't know that
was a thing i didn't know i
i did i just thought of it i'm like
maybe that'll work
yeah i mean it's worked a little bit
i uh
i typically go with the whole like tea
routine you know like you know calm the
throat you know some people do like the
uh like when you're sick they'll do the
garlic lemon tea thing yeah oh that's
disgusting i think
my my daughter lost her voice because of
allergies i think it's that i had the
same problem here
i do that like i don't know you were
just talking too much twice and it just
got well that's probably that might be i
talk a lot of [ __ ] i talk a lot of [ __ ]
so so um i i showed him the poll for the
uh
the bone hint of the week of course we
all know who won oh yeah there no i will
say i added a couple in there last
minute that were uh for the dishonorable
mention in the alpha cuck which i think
are appropriate right well i and i
downloaded those and i put those in and
i haven't really taken a look at but you
know what i was i was thinking
is that there's a lot of boneheads on
the trends this morning like we could do
a whole new poll right now and probably
i mean lindsey graham is have you talked
about lindsey graham yet
uh well a little bit i i avoided i
avoided um well oh wait are you talking
about how he wants he wants a
stoffenberg he wants to want he
basically yeah he wants a brutus
involved yeah which i think is ironic
right just my only two cents on this is
like one i'm not saying
he's wrong or right
about what he said because i do feel uh
you know
potentially the only way to stop putin
is from within his party now whether
that's uh diplomatically or uh or some
other way right like he's suggesting now
i'm not saying
that's not a thing that should be done
i'm just saying as a a sitting u.s
senator probably not smart to go out and
tweet that and go on a show and and put
that out there well i mean here's the
thing no i want nothing more than for
vladimir putin
to
keep his dirt nap appointment
i want that right right like it really
is past time for his dirt map
appointment as far as i'm concerned but
at the same time
you are correct and then it's probably
not a good idea for like a
really prominent politician to say go
murder him right
especially with someone who uh you know
he's calling for a brutus but he himself
uh was unwilling not to say that he
would be the brutus that would take out
uh
um
you know trump but
uh it i do find it ironic that he's
saying the only way to stop this person
and it's you know fascist state and as a
dictator is to remove him
uh you know in a life death capacity
and then you look at
trump and he said [ __ ]
you know he was so far up that ass that
he had just a whole like goatee of [ __ ]
you know right right well i mean i mean
the the the long of the short of it is
is that trump should feel lucky that his
attempt to be a dictator here
didn't end
at him with at the end of a rope which
is what putin's going to that's right
yeah i i imagine that putin is going to
be found in a bunker
of that he's taken his own life um
because he is a weak piece of [ __ ] yeah
um he's a weak piece of [ __ ] and i think
that's probable
there we go that's you now
yep
um so
yeah i agree that uh he is a a weak
piece of [ __ ] as you said uh you know
it's considering a guy who sits at one
end of the table and is like 50 yards
away from
uh anyone who's gonna be reporting on
him because he's like either one i fear
for my life because you assassinate me
two i fear for my life kids will give me
covet or three
uh
you know i i'm not actually the person
in power um right like everyone thinks i
am i don't know
anyway
yeah we want to go to bonehead is that
what we want to do we can jump into
bonehead you know i just want to give
you time to rest up oh yeah
then you're robin right
man i'm robin i don't know if that's how
that's not how robin actually talks uh
he probably talks more like me uh
because i am robin you know let's let's
get to bonehead of the week here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if that doesn't fix your your throat
problems then i don't know what will you
know that tune right
right well
it happens
it happens and it happened when and when
you when what you're doing is trying to
um
make sounds with your vocal cords right
and your vocal cords aren't working that
well yeah it did crazy concept too you
know it's like i just gotta do this and
i i thought about this morning telling
everyone hey i ain't got the voice but
you know it's like nah i'm not gonna
give up [ __ ] it i'm not gonna [ __ ] him
i'm not gonna
you know what if you took the day off
you'd be only you know uh
strengthening these idiots by now that's
right that's right if we are quiet then
they are going to be more loud you know
speaking of boneheads and idiots being
loud
speaking of boneheads being loud yeah we
had we had three contestants
look at that middle finger huh that's
nice yeah
that's about what she is right yeah of
course we had bobo the clown her foot
green
and then kim reynolds yeah can you can
you tell can you tell the audience why
we had these three on the list
yeah so kim reynolds uh governor of iowa
uh found herself on the list because uh
she you know part of the giving the
state of the union uh
response the the official gop response
because of course marcher taylor green
had her own america first one that was
just a [ __ ]
hilarious [ __ ] show
uh but yeah uh she of course uh you know
the the approach even before she did
that it was her approach of blaming um
blaming biden and then
afterward she was still blaming biden
um even though he had said things like
oh we need to fund the police and we
need to give them resources they're you
know she was still it's like they did
not listen to anything that was said
and still went with the scripted
uh statement of response because they
felt like they knew what he was going to
say and then he mentioned that things
that actually are
pro-republican on their side
and she just sounds like an idiot
so
it was uh not only that but she's
another person of their side that pushes
their narrative and no one can get the
narrative straight you know
something's going great blame biden
uh you know whether it's ukraine russia
it's the economy it's the you know the
biden boom the job is 3.8 percent
unemployment right now which is amazing
and of course they'll find some way to
blame it on biden but that's all they
are and that's all she did and you know
outside of that it's like kim reynolds
is an irrelevant hack
and uh
tried to use as an opportunity to
bolster herself as a candidate for
whatever she wants to do politically
next and it was a pretty laughable
estate there's a bunch of clips online
of uh that people had shared um
but i ha i have one here from
the if you go to the kim reynolds
thread who's at the top
look at that
you guys you guys put the pole at the
very top
so boom um but here here is a clip that
recount did um they say
iowa governor kim reynolds her words
versus her actions let's see you
shouldn't have to wake up every morning
and worry about the next thing the
government is going to do to you
your business or your children
republican governor of iowa iowa kim
reynolds signed a bill banning
transgender girls from taking part in
girls sports
oh that that pesky yeah that government
huh right that pesky government telling
you what to do and who to love and who
to be at pesky government my body my
choice except
when i feel uncomfortable yeah right
your [ __ ] pieces same thing you know
who else i didn't even put on the list
that i just thought of right now yeah
goddamn desantis [ __ ] that guy yeah [ __ ]
that [ __ ] them dude are you talking
about the mass thing really
i had a tweet that was like oh you know
he
he's some he's oddly triggered by other
people wearing masks on their own body
right they made a choice and i was like
what happened with you know my body my
choice
and a lot of people were like yes
i understand what's being said here
there is a hypocrisy whether or not at
the end he was like fine wear the mask
if you want or whatever this is all like
covet theater
and i had some people who came into my
comments a couple people and i quickly
checked them
because they were like
here's a screenshot of when he said if
you want to wear it fine right and i
said you mean after he told them to wear
it and they're like
so
he gave them a choice
and i was like
the great thing about having your own
body and being autonomous is that it is
your choice right you are the one who
decides what you will and will not do
it's it's called liberty right now i and
my response to one of these [ __ ]
dumbasses was like oh i didn't know that
it was his choice to give to those kids
right i was too distracted by the fact
that a sitting florida governor just
shamed a bunch of kids using coveted
disinformation about masks to say take
it off right and even the parents of
those kids came out and said this is
this is unacceptable like do not talk to
my kids that way you know whatever yeah
well number one don't get within five
feet of my [ __ ] kid you [ __ ] radio
exactly don't be telling my kid what
they can and can't do right
and the other thing too is like if any
of those kids was a like oh republican
pro desantis type person like holy [ __ ]
did you just alienate yourself from that
future donor as well as their parents
because who the [ __ ] walks in these kids
you know selected with for whatever
reason standing back there on the
backdrop of uh
of the speech and he comes in and goes
take the mask off take the max off you
don't you don't need those masks and
it's like what type of welcome do you
does that you know do you feel
when you have the governor of your state
come in and say take it off that's dumb
it's covet theater those don't work also
from a guy who hasn't won
especially when they were they were the
props these kids were having props
behind him but he didn't want that it
was all the image of like florida no
mass strong except i even think uh
uh
the
um
defunct junction i think is they did a
thing about it and they've de-functioned
yeah
they did a whole thing about how like
the
the cases and the deaths and and because
the population relatively is the same
between new york and florida and
actually showed them to say like oh uh
the debts are uh
uh many times greater
in florida than they are in new york so
get the [ __ ] out of here with this whole
mass don't work [ __ ] right well you know
you know speaking of mask and choice and
all that kind of stuff that's kind of
why the other two are on the bonehead of
the week because we we not only have
governor kim reynolds we also have
lauren bobert and marjorie taylor green
that the thing that i like about the
most about what happened at the state of
the union is that
none of those people were forced to wear
a mask
and the reason why is because joe
biden's the president right that's
that's the reason why because he's
worked and the administration has worked
the congress has worked democrats have
worked democrats only have worked to try
to put an end to this pandemic
and the reason why that they were able
to choose to wear a mask or not on the
floor at that point
during the stadium is because democrats
have worked so hard to end this thing
right and right now
in
most of the country you don't need to
wear a mask if you don't have a reason
to
like those children that were behind
desantis they had a reason someone
pointed out the other day
and it might have been on midas touch
podcast last night because they were
talking about this
um they were talking about how
you know how does desantis know if
someone in their family is
immunocompromised i'm like well how the
[ __ ] does he know that they're not right
exactly i mean yet sometimes maybe those
kids are [ __ ] sick like i wouldn't go
right now with my voice the way the way
it is i wouldn't i wouldn't go in public
without wearing a mask yeah i don't i
don't know i mean i think i know that
it's allergies because i haven't run a
fever i mean i i had a scratchy throat
but i don't know
so if i go into public i'm definitely
going to put on a mask and especially
coming from a from a guy whose wife is
right it has cancer recovery
cancer delighted it's insane to be like
you know what
i'm gonna put my wife at risk because of
political covet theater and that's what
it is the guy who says covet theater
he's
the one if it wasn't a big like here's
thing it wouldn't be like it is theater
because he's making
uh drama about it if he didn't say
anything about it it wouldn't be theater
well the reason why gabe the reason why
he has to make bones about it is because
of his if his [ __ ] ridiculous
followers saw him standing there with
people with masks behind him he's weak
because he didn't make him take him off
he's not a fascist he's not a true
fascist if he didn't make those people
take them off you know you know a weak
fascist is not what they need
speaking of weak fascists marjorie
taylor green um described the audience
what what
what led us to put
marjorie taylor green
on the bone end of the week
yeah she uh she did her own um
she was the official response uh person
for america first
and
went on some crazy conspiracy rant about
uh joe biden
joe biden hunter biden
uh
ukraine russia
and
uh it was just the [ __ ] bananas like
no one should i mean uh if you do we
have a clip of that
um yeah let me see if i can pull it out
go ahead and keep i'll see if i can but
yeah so basically for those who did not
watch uh marger taylor green just went
off the [ __ ] cliff per usual
um and started talking about why joe
biden is actually america first it's the
america first yeah yeah exactly um
and yeah she goes on this whole thing
and i feel like i've seen a clip of that
it's like a minute long or so but
basically uh marjory taylor green is
just pushing this idea that joe you know
joe biden's weak and he's acting
he's at there there's a whole like if i
remember it was like a blackmail
situation that was happening like it was
just very odd
about drugs and [ __ ] right yeah yeah
very odd uh uh conspiracy theory that
she's pushing i think this is it isn't
it a patriarchy yeah yeah yeah is this
is this the one you're looking for okay
let's let's play this here
you're right to say i want to know what
drugs he was on last night because the
man was this is
he couldn't even stop talking you know
normally when someone gives a speech and
the audience claps or rises with a
standing ovation usually the speaker
will pause in their speech allow the
audience to finish finish clapping or
the volume to come down and then they
they start going again with their speech
joe biden was so juiced up on joe biden
he just kept talking every time that the
democrats would cheer for him he just
kept going painting from screen to
screen on the teleprompter and he never
slowed down it's like he wasn't capable
of reading them yeah okay i can't take
anymore then
um she's making i mean
though
they call him sleepy joe and now they're
mad he was too lively right right
exactly homie be too hyped that he's
doing a good job well that's that's
where the drug thing comes in right it's
unbelievable that they would um
again it's they they are never happy
because they'll be criticizing you like
oil prices or gas prices are too high
and not out of this and it's like okay
well we work with these people and now
supply
improving supply chain and oil prices
and gas prices are going down they're
like
it's not quick enough it's not too
it's not enough and it's like dude
[ __ ] chill man like you have a
problem he's a president he's working on
a solution he then
does actually act on it and fix or begin
to fix a problem and then you aren't
happy because it's not either happening
fast enough or he did a good job and you
don't want to give credit
i mean speaking of uh
speaking of these
two these two [ __ ]
they gotta turn their they turn their
backs they're so [ __ ] weak man she's
like so are we gonna go we're gonna have
some crew
screw top wine later or uh what did she
call it is that what she called that one
time she's like i'm not a screw top girl
yeah i'm not a screw top girl she's
definitely not a screw top girl for sure
it's more like a well what what the hell
the bag wine she's not even a box wine
it's probably the bad one yeah as i'm
saying franzia baby that's that photo
and i was like who's is like uh
uh what i forgot what i tweeted it was
basically it was the photo of them
yelling
and
uh it's like you're telling me you're
out of franzia
where's this video of her
is it this one yep that's it
this is 30 seconds this is rsbn you know
i don't want to play this [ __ ] oh god
so tonight i'm calling for an american
revival a revival of spirit a revival of
courage a revival of unity
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
this ain't real is it this has got to be
[ __ ] fake
this is a deep fake this has got to be a
defeat
come on man
are you serious we need to reject the
politics of race and division we need to
come together as one american family
this has got to be a d fake this can't
be real thing is she could say it
uninterrupted and uh
uh
and make sure that she gets out she's
like look i'm saying something in a
normal calm tone
uh let me see if i can miss
the actual video
the video on that yeah
so um she's also she also was on the
list because of how she what she did at
cpac and i want to show that
i'm here while you're looking up then
because she did some totally vile [ __ ]
at cpac she actually went and she spoke
at a nazi rally the american first
whatever the [ __ ] it the nazi rally is
what it is
um of course kevin mccarthy cupped on
her too by not giving a response oh is
he
uh i think i think this yeah here joshua
jason's excuse me has it here here's the
the video from robert uh costa
uh questioning her why she went to a
nazi rally let's listen stop i have got
to get in the airport but i'm glad to
talk to you about this i do not know
nick fuentes
bull [ __ ] [ __ ]
bull [ __ ] [ __ ] you don't know nick
fuentes
come on do you believe that [ __ ]
yeah
do you do you gave do you believe no no
of course not of course not
there's also a video the suppose i guess
there's also a video of uh from right
wing watch that has
uh nick fuentes
is now uh as they s here i'll send you
the link i haven't watched the video but
basically it was in response to her
state of the union address and they were
saying that he is uh
is simping for her
as the kids call it
oh yeah the kids
is that what it is
okay copy let's let's let's never heard
him speak i've never seen a video i
don't know what his views are so i'm not
i've never heard him speak and i've
never reversal but i can't tell you
because i went to she accepted it just
right she went to his event she yeah she
went to an event that won uh you most
definitely have a team that [ __ ] does
a vet of that to make sure like oh she's
not walking into a trap or some sort of
wait a second wait a second because this
thing's called the america first
whatever
i i i remember there is a sitting
uh congresswoman from georgia who goes
with the sitting
member of congress from florida they go
all around the country
to uh different events and i believe
they call them i believe the two words
that they use
most often is america first i don't know
who those people are i don't know i
can't put my finger on it right right i
can't put my fascist finger on it but
yeah um [ __ ] idiot trust his very
large following because that is a young
it's a very young following and it's a
gender yeah you like to tap into a bunch
of nazis
excuse me excuse me a minute i'll tell
you exactly why i went i went to talk to
them about america first policies and i
talked to them about what's important
for our country going forward america
first policies you hear that she's gonna
go talk to them about america first
policies well yeah that's what it was
called america first
yeah
duh
we it was a nazi rally to begin with and
you're a nazi and you were gonna go talk
to other nazis she's like oh these these
young white men these young white men we
need to we need to save their souls or
some [ __ ] what
out of here now in regards to russia
putin is a murderer and he's what the
[ __ ] that is a that is a weird
transition when you go from i just want
what's best for america yeah we shifted
real hard we went from uh hey
i don't know the guy anyway let's talk
about how russian ukraine is joe biden's
fault oh she jumped straight to it
didn't she no no hesitation she's like
yeah murderous she's thinking murder
murderous fascism here in the united
states nazis
putin like boom her mind goes straight
to it
he should have never invaded ukraine
what he is doing is completely wrong
does it look like does it look like you
were allies
and i'm completely against this war does
it look like she believes that when
she's saying it i mean she's like um i
mean she's so [ __ ] definitely like
nuts and dumb i'm like she could very
well believe that and at the same time
like she could not believe that i just
don't know like she's not that
intelligent
and i believe that she i don't know it's
like
i'm just gonna say yeah she believes it
yeah so here's right wing watch this is
the link that you sent me um we all know
who this [ __ ] this scumbag is this is
this is
yeah i don't know what this clip is i've
never seen it but let's see
i thought it was very good and delivered
very well i thought the
execution was very good
she looked uh very presidential i would
say
i don't know if i necessarily support a
woman president but that's very
presidential very very
states statesmen like states women like
that was good immigration moratorium
someone pointed out secure the border
deport all the illegals very good
pro-life very racist very fascist you
know very white right right she looks
really white she's i mean she's
definitely whiter than nick fuentes
yeah
yeah i mean nick points the only time
she gets uh any color in her face is
after she does a crossfit workout and
then she's like i did
right now she's like put their face like
you know
and
really he probably loves those videos
too oh yeah i'm sure he's like oh yeah
that was all very very very he's
struggling to
uh give a woman compliments yeah it's
very interesting to watch him be like uh
how do i compliment her while still
being a misogynist you know right right
how do i how do i compliment anything
but maybe the way her body looks like
she she taught she said words she she
has she has brain brain maybe may be
good uh even though brain has vagina uh
brain brain good uh i don't he he can't
figure it out he can't like say yeah
she's she's fine
he's yeah trying to he's having a
difficult time trying to find even the
easiest things to compliment her on but
it does seem like it does seem like he
knew she was coming she knew oh yeah he
was gonna be there everybody knew you
have to know everyone has to everyone
involved coordinating your time for a
schedule you can't just ad hoc be like
i'm going to stop by i mean you know
maybe you could but this was certainly
planned because they even talked about
that and they're like
we have this person coming up to talk
and she comes in she smiles shakes the
hand da-da-da takes the photos super
[ __ ] pumped about it and then when
she's confronted because
oh [ __ ] people are actually concerned
about nick fuentes she goes never never
heard of him haven't ever seen the video
never talk i think he's a coffee boy
isn't it yeah isn't he a coffee boy
well
it's
right wing watch says after marjory
taylor green spoke at his white
nationalist half pack
that's kind of weird comment no you know
what wait sorry take it back and say
afpak just like the commercial though
yeah f-back yeah there you go
back yeah
yeah half-pack you could be like a
maybe if i get my voice back i could do
it better nick fuentes is now simping
for her like you said
the kids say sympathy does the kids say
that's the consent what does that mean
exactly uh it's you are uh if you're a
symp for someone or something then you
are um you like fawn over it
that's why i say like all these [ __ ]
maga heads are uh right wing
they they simp
for right-wing terrorism right they love
it they'll do whatever they're like oh
my god oh my god ain't complimenting
they'll [ __ ] do anything
for that right uh so he's simping for
her because he's like you know he's
complimenting he's like very
presidential yeah you know like she said
that she said that you know oh yeah very
nice even after the fact she was like i
don't know this guy now whether he knew
that or like read between the lines in a
way and was like oh she just has to say
that for the cameras well we both know
we [ __ ] love each other well
apparently this is a video because it
says check out his reaction to her right
this is after after her response which
was you know after the video
exactly okay let's retweet this i'm not
going to play the rest of that [ __ ]
because i can't stand to listen to that
song actually [ __ ] nazi
um did you see the video of the clip of
him on stage at his app pack i'm talking
about how he's hitler or some [ __ ] and
[ __ ] yeah it's uh i mean i remember
uh right before he got banned versus
permanently suspended from twitter it
was because he was making a comparison
he was talking about the holocaust and
cooking uh and making baking cookies
and he was using that as an analogy yeah
yeah and that's what everyone was like
this is you know he's like oh well if
you bake these mini cookies and you have
the this many ovens and this
and whatever and it's like okay can we
just call what it is this guy's clearly
using an example of uh how to talk about
the holocaust and murdering jews uh this
is not okay this is hate speech this is
terrible and then he finally was taken
off speaking of hate speech we our
winner is lauren boober but i want to
move first to uh your dishonorable
mention which is thomas massey thomas
east thomas the racist massey this guy
voted no
on the he was one of three people who
voted no on the anti-lynching bill
pro lynching crow lynching the bill was
like hey
lynching that's a hate crime you should
be uh charged for that [ __ ] that's not
acceptable anymore this is 2022 and
massey goes
yeah he was like yeah
nah
i i've got a couple you know nooses in
the back in the back shed and it's like
dude
like
technically technically there was two
other [ __ ] right the reason why thomas
massey kind of gets the brunt of the uh
the dishonorable mentioneers because
he's the same [ __ ] idiot who took
christmas pictures with um
guns with his family in front of our
christmas trees if that has anything to
do with you know jesus or god or
christianity or anything like that right
but he's also uh
he also voted against
uh was it ukrainian aid yep well the
support of ukraine right
you know they were voting to stand with
ukraine and he voted against that i
believe it was him paul goes our maybe
two others i don't remember but he was
on the list so uh congratulations to
thomas mask he's been on our bonehead
several times yeah he's he's been he's
been yeah he's bounced around since
december when he [ __ ] sent that
[ __ ] christmas card i mean
here's the thing when matt gatz finally
does get indicted for sex trafficking
and has to go to federal prison maybe
thomas massey will
take uh oh maddie's place yeah in in the
congress so
okay so let's move to alphacut because i
want to get to the winner here but alpha
cuck you had jeff younger
now tell us tell the audience who jeff
younger is why i uh why is
younger here he is uh anti-lgbtq
he's a gq peer he was at the university
of uh uh north texas unt right northern
texas yes it was uh he went there for a
talk yeah and denton i believe is where
it says yeah yeah
and
um
he went there and was immediately
protested by a bunch of students uh in
the in in the hall like classroom that
he was speaking at and it's pretty great
i think you shared a video it's got a
few million views i actually i actually
uh posted on tick tock right i think
it's got like three and a half million
views this morning um that was not my
intention i was just trying to give
people this this video right of this
thing so people could see it um i pulled
it off of twitter
from the original poster here's the
original video that i pulled it from
here it has two
of these right right which uh for people
who don't know or follow this this video
got reported
by a bunch of and you know uh and right
wing and anti-ashes
that he was getting uh chanted against
in this right so the video comes down
and it says this video was removed
and uh then andy no
in his typical fashion will lie about
what was what actually happened so he
went out there and claimed victory to
say like oh oh look
this person got caught and they deleted
their video when naturality what
happened was the video got reported by a
bunch of [ __ ] fascists and then was
put back up yesterday i think
yeah yeah well i i had messaged you
because i noticed that it was down right
um i had put it up on on tick tock now
no one [ __ ] with the video on tick
tock that i know of because it never
went down um it got a few thousand views
i think in the first couple hours and
then all of a sudden i checked it later
and i had
uh thousands of notifications
and um it it i think right now it's got
like three three and a half million
views over on tick tock here it has two
and a half million views on this post on
on twitter and i believe other people
have circulated around so i'm sure this
videos get
tens of millions of views if you've
added in a month oh like probably yeah
but there is there is a good reason for
that and let me show you why
i want to point something out here this
is very important
everyone keeps calling this this person
standing up here in a suit of professors
it's not the [ __ ] professor that's
that [ __ ] bigot uh jeff younger jeff
younger um
if everyone doesn't know has a has a
transgender
daughter and um he didn't want her to be
transgender and he tried to fight for
her not to be transgender and he didn't
win that fight with the mother and so
now what he's trying to do is make sure
all transgender people
are ostracized from society because he's
a [ __ ] fascist mind he's my choice
right he's not just a [ __ ] fascist
towards other people's children he'll
he's a fascist towards his own children
and someone someone uh
i don't know on tick tock i watched
several of the the duets or whatever
they're called
on tick tock that someone sent me and
someone said that i was endangering
these people by posting this video and
i'm like i'm endangering these people
jeff younger
jeff younger and the republicans in
texas right they want they want to get
rid of these people in society these
people are brave these these college
students that are doing this are [ __ ]
brave
and if this country can do anything they
can learn a thing or two about
i'm starting to get my voice back with
this
they can learn a [ __ ] thing or two
from these students that they that
whether you're transgender or you're not
you should stand for humanity you stand
for equality in equity
and really at the end of the day this
[ __ ] standing up there mocking these
people right um because i don't think
his attention his intention was to look
like the professor in the video
some people thought he was but if you
look at the slide it says for the future
of texas
uh federalism
and state nationalism
conservatives uh what's it say here
conservatives
as
something republican
republican politics
as restoration yeah they want to restore
in other words they want to cleanse
that's what it says is cleanse and
they're talking about [ __ ] humans
right i don't care whatever whatever the
human wants to do right rather you agree
with her don't agree with it and i got a
lot of that stupid [ __ ] and comments too
that oh they're just they're drowning
him out because he has a different
opinion nope not a difference that's not
yeah no no it's not an opi your opinion
can be that you don't think that that
you should be forced to be transgender
that is a an opinion you can have that
is an opinion you can have you can
actually believe that transgender people
are sinners or whatever
but you do not you do not get to take
away their [ __ ] humanity that's not
something you get to do that is not a
choice and that is not an opinion and we
must we must in this country be
intolerant of intolerance and i believe
that's what these students were doing
right and anyone who says oh you're
putting their lives at risk no no no
that that is not what's happening this
is just broadcasting the message further
so people see that if these people if
these students really felt like their
lives were in danger they would not have
shown up right right or if they did they
felt that that showing up was worth
getting in trouble that's well the other
thing too is let's talk why their lives
are in danger their lives are in danger
not because these students are speaking
out for equality and equity
it's because of people who want to
[ __ ] kill
equality and equity literally kill it so
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
yeah um that me helping these people
spread their message so people can see
what is happening in texas
this is the whole sunlight is the best
disinfectant
you cannot look away from this stuff you
have to see this stuff what they're
doing now some argued all well
why did they let this person come on
campus i actually am glad they let jeff
younger try to come and speak his
[ __ ] hate speech on this campus
because let's watch the rest of the
video and then i'll show you the
beginning
now you see here there's some of his
aids up here front and they got maga
hats on yeah but if you look back here
in the back there are some people at
some point that aren't cheering let me
turn it down a bit so we can talk
but you see there's some people out
there in the back that aren't cheering
yeah that's because they're part of some
republican group that invited jeff
younger these students are the brave
ones that came in and said no we're
gonna be tolerant it's not just students
inside there are videos of them outside
as well right right because there was a
protest beforehand exactly and
everyone's like oh they shouldn't have
let him on campus like
you know
you know if anything it only uh it only
shows that there is
free speech
that you can go you could say the
dumbest [ __ ] you want right like it
could be super vile
and they they say listen you know as an
institution we have to give both sides
whether it's right or wrong uh of uh the
uh the option to to to speak right right
and uh
all these right wing idiots shouldn't
get mad
they hit they were able to express their
first amendment speech their first
amendment right right to free speech so
don't say anyone's trying to suppress
your vote they came in and these
students also expressed their first
amendment right in speaking out in
protesting
so anyone who tries to say from the
right oh this isn't fair or not another
being mean and bullying shut the [ __ ] up
because both sides were able to come in
and they were both able to express
themselves using their first amendment
right
even though his opinion and his thing
that he had to say was [ __ ]
disgusting it's vile it's hate speech is
what it is but he's covering it up as
this powerpoint presentation which is
talking about conservativism and
reformism and all this [ __ ] no kiss my
ass so you notice here his little uh his
yes
abbott fan yeah abbott for governor and
then the [ __ ] make america great
again
and then this is jeff younger here
laughing it up
um these are the these are the
intolerant and we should be intolerant
of them so
um know who jeff younger is that that
guy in the front is not the professor
yeah
it is it is jeff younger that [ __ ]
bigot okay let's go back to um
uh
do let's go back to the
winner we have uh lauren bobert is the
winner bonehead of the week
how many times has she won this isn't
the first oh yeah i don't know a handful
i'm beginning to lose count i maybe i
should just have a uh
you should have a running list i know i
i should do record record keepers
i would have to look at it but i'll have
a you know what here just for this i'll
just say let's say let's say
let's say bobo has
uh okay he he wants to use his
whiteboard folks he's been wanting to
use it for a while look at him he thinks
he's okay what is bobo's count what is
are you talking about one or been on one
one you think she's won five i don't
know i'd have to go back and look at all
that i'd say i'd say three i'd give her
three
give her three she's one
there we go okay just implement she's
all right she's just always on it until
i know the actual account she is
infinite okay
i feel like a goddamn sportscaster over
here [ __ ] drawing please he's got to
go up
right right well let's let's give the
bonehead of the week her do
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so so gabe tell the audience why
why this [ __ ] bonehead made it
lauren
well she she uh put the nail on the
coffin yesterday but what she did was
during the state of the union this dumb
[ __ ]
says
during the speech when joe biden
gets to the point talking about uh
soldiers who have been harmed um from
the the
the fire pits and who have been you know
come back and either get cancer or that
you know they're
they're injured and she goes 13.
you killed 13 of them right she had a
plan too she yeah oh no there's video
where where it shows where she's like
looking over
and then says it so it's all [ __ ]
it's all planned then
after getting called out for this
[ __ ] [ __ ] that she decides to
spew during the middle of state of the
union and what's funny here is i made a
joke
at the beginning of the state of the
union and i brought up uh joe wilson and
if anyone remembers who joe wilson is in
2009 joe wilson was the guy who yelled
out you lie right
and
he yelled out you lie and he was uh he
was reprimanded by
the the house um
but he did that and then got a bunch of
[ __ ] for it right
and i made a joke of like oh who's gonna
be the first one on the republicans to
yell out let's go brandon right
no one said it that i know of right but
then she comes out and she does this
right the 13. here here's here's the
moment where she says joe biden's about
to talk about beau biden everyone in the
room everyone in the nation
knows who he's about to talk about of a
flag-draped coffin of his son right and
here's what she says
i know
[Music]
flag
she says you put them there 13 of them
let's listen to it again drake coffin
i know
[Music]
you put them there like who is she who
is she looking off to i want to know
who's on the other side i think she's
looking at marjory taylor green here uh
marjorie taylor green was sitting to her
right
um if you go back let me go back here to
the thread let me give credit to the u.s
singers here
so yeah so uh she's i actually think she
is looking at marjory taylor green she's
i think they had an agreement that one
of them was going to say it
and you know she was first on it that's
why she picked up her phone
um
she maybe she wanted a recording of it
what is it no no it looks like martial
agreement to the right to the left of
her
she is you're right you're right
maybe i am wrong so i don't know who
she's looking is she looking at well
someone else
thought she said something else let's
look at this
see what this is are you going to get in
trouble with daniel dale with this i
have a feeling when i play this daniel
dale is going to be now up in our grill
and have it counted
and look i just tweeted nancy pelosi's
location is that what she said
oh my god no caitlyn does caitlyn does
bring up a good point here there was
that there was that uh video and i
haven't looked at oh okay because he was
sitting down in the front this is this
is uh this was madison catherine he sat
there and he was he was like looking
down
and then i kind of like looked up and
looked back down so i don't know if that
was the cue or when that was
but i would have to go back and look at
the footage but that's what i that's
what that's what uh kalyn is referring
to right now now not only this but she
says this
and then oh god you [ __ ] build the
wall [ __ ]
yeah well so go ahead and then i'll play
the build-a-wall so what happened next
was and why it made my tweets so much
more relevant is that she yelled this
out while he was talking about um cl uh
flag draped coffins and his son
so like i don't care where you stand on
the aisle where you are politically it's
[ __ ] up anyway
then she tweeted doubling down on why
she had to speak out against it
is that why she picked up her phone
no no no she tweeted after that
yeah this is afterwards because she was
getting a bunch of [ __ ] for and she's
like i felt like once i heard that i had
to speak up i had to say something
goddamn right i support the troops and
then i'll let you play this and then
yesterday she put herself back in
in by tripling down here's here's the
bill the walmart
it's hard to hear them because they're
[ __ ] idiots
so then yesterday they had a vote on uh
healthcare for vets right in the house
yeah what happened with that
174 republicans voted against it
and wait wait wait wait wait wait that
can't be
republican
sorry to bust your bubble there tony but
that's what happened and they voted
against helping us you know support the
troops
and who was on that list
[ __ ] bobo bobert okay
of course she
just two days prior says i had to speak
out because i support the troops and i
had to say what i had to say
and then
she goes and doubles down on it and does
an interview triples down on it and says
i did it because i support the troops
god damn it and then yesterday this vote
comes and she goes
[ __ ] them [ __ ] those troops yeah she's
like you guys need health care or some
sort of care once you uh once you come
out
bonehead what a [ __ ] bonehead good
luck thank you lauren for participating
again in the bone of the week let's give
her one last do before we go
[Applause]
[Music]
and there i give you bone end of the
week go follow at tony michael's pod to
vote every week bonehead of the week
follow me at the tony michaels and that
i am gabe sanchez gabe we passed a
thousand subscribers on the youtube
channel today
we passed a thousand followers on the
tony michaels pod twitter account boom
shakalaka
i think that's i think that is
successful in the um in the bonehead of
the week
and if anyone is yeah yeah and i was
gonna say if anyone hasn't seen the
interview that we did with uh high
fidelity yesterday well i'm go check it
out i'm gonna come right back let's
let's do the bone of the week we'll come
back for a couple minutes and we'll just
stick with us around after the song here
we're gonna talk a little more
[Music]
[Applause]
all right the bonehead of the week that
was a uh very interesting course always
with bobert marjorie taylor green
um so you were saying about the
interview because it uh tell everyone
about the interview again it is on the
youtube channel
so we did an interview with high
fidelity he is a uh a veteran
technologist as he says and uh
uh he is also the co-host of
radicalized truth matters our truth
survives podcast
um
uh we had previously heidi kuda on the
show uh and basically what we talked
about during the interview with high
fidelity was he dug into the data of the
the the donor data leak that happened
from gibson go and he found some very
interesting but also very
unusually suspect things that indicate
you know
fraud money laundering a lot of you know
uh one email
with multiple different credit cards in
multiple different locations with
multiple different names going out and
being donated to this uh this freedom
convoy in canada so it does raise an
eyebrow to you know who or what is
funding this type of right-wing
extremism
um but it's it's it's a great interview
it's a couple hours long um
but it takes a lot of stuff and we try
to make it simple right so some people
understand what you're looking at
because it is difficult with this data
and the leaking and what it all means so
we try to make that clear but go
subscribe to channel go watch that
interview it's it's fascinating it's not
surprising but it's fascinating and um i
think we're there's still a couple
stories that are being worked on and
maybe we'll tweet those out once if any
of that drops uh bigger stories of
people
not just high five but some other people
looking at that data so
um we'll try to drop those stories if
those come and so subscribe to the
youtube channel thank you everybody for
uh for subscribing we've reached a
thousand
don't let it stop though yeah
it's not there keep going keep
subscribing keep voting on both end of
the week you gotta practice voting every
week that's yeah the purpose is just get
it in
the motion yeah that the the act of
democracy right remember every single
weekday rather i have a [ __ ] voice or
not
every single weekday even if i have to
talk like bad man batman
every [ __ ] list
[ __ ]
noon eastern 11 central
youtube twitter twitch every single
weekday
until next week [ __ ] em
crackers surf's up
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking